واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على
نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
وقراءتنا موصوله
في
كتاب
الامام القيم
ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى
في كتاب
زاد المعاد
هدي خير العباد
في جمع
والتوفيق بين
احاديث وسنن وايام رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم
وقد وصلنا فيه الى
تغيير اتجاه القبله
ان الله عز وجل حول القبله وحول جهه
الصلاه
من بيت المقدس الى
الى بيت الله الحرام في مكه
وقد قال الله تعالى لنبيه في ذلك قد نرى
تقلب وجهك في السماء
فلنولينك قبله ترضاها
وولي وجهك شطر المسجد الحرام
او لله تعالى شطر المسجد الحرام شطر
كلمه شاطر
في
اصلها
شين والطاء والراء
فان المقصود منها في هذا
السياق شطر المسجد الحرام يعني الى
وسط المسجد الحرام يطلق
كلمه شطر
ويراد به
نصف الشيء
ويطلق شاطر ويراد به
نحو الشيء او اتجاه الشيء
هنا قول الله تعالى فولي وجهك
شطر المسجد الحرام معناه ان المصلي اذا
كان على ظاهره
معناها ان المصلي لابد ان يتجه الى
عقر المسجد الحرام الى وسطه لا ينحرف عنه
شيئا
ولكن
جاء عند الحاكم رحمه الله
عن علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
انه قال في قول الله تعالى فولي وجهك
شطر المسجد الحرام قال نحوه
يعني الى جهه المسجد الحرام
في فرك
بين المعنيين
الامام الشافعي رحمه الله
فيما اشتهر عنه
اخذ بظاهر الايه
وذلك انه
لا يجوز للمصلي ان ينحرف عن القبله ولو
سانتي وهو يعلم
والائمه الثلاثه
وهو الراجح
ان المقصود بشطر المسجد الحرام ما جاء هنا
عن علي رضي الله عنه اي نحو المسجد الحرام
يعني على الجهه العامه
التي فيها المسجد الحرام
اذا نظرنا الى عامه المساجد المبنيه
من زمن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم الى يوم
الناس هذا نجد ان اتجاه القبله في هذه
المساجد المعين
قد يكون
منحرف عن البوصله شيئا يسيرا لا يضر ولا
يؤثر
وبعض الناس يظن ان هذا يؤثر في الصلاه وفي
صحه صلاه المصلين في هذه المساجد وهذا
الكلام ليس بصحيح
بل النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فهمنا معنى شطر المسجد الحرام
فقال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما بين المشرق والمغرب قبله
ابين المشرق والمغرب قبل ايش يعني هذا
الكلام يعني الذي في المدينه
اذا جعل اذا جعل
المغرب الى يمينه
والمشرق الى يساره فامامه قبله المصلي
قبله المسلم
طيب هم في المدينه هل المدينه بالضبط
بالضبط الى شمال الكعبه الجواب لا
كعبه انت في المدينه
الاتجاه شيء يسير الى المشرق
لكن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اكتفى بهذا
بهذا العموم
فمن ذلك فاهم علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله
عنه امير المؤمنين فهم ان قول الله تعالى
شطر المسجد الحرام يعني ايش يعني نحو
المسجد الحرام
العلماء اجمعوا على ان من كان يرى
الكعبه
فان صلاته تفسد اذا لم يتجه اليها بل يتجه
الى الكعبه اذا كان يراها ما في عذر
لكن اذا كان الانسان لا يرى الكعبه
فان الجهه العامه تكفي العلماء يذكرون
نحوا من ثلاثين
او نحو
الثلاثين درجه
في ايامنا هذا فتاوى العلماء يقولون
مثلا واحد صلى
صلى الى جهه وجد ان القبله شيء يسير الى
اليسار او شيء يسير الى اليمين هل يعيد
الصلاه الجواب لا
ما دام انه لم ينحرف عن القبله
اكثر من 30 درجه
30 درجه يعني اذا كانت
القبله هكذا
يولد وجهه اتجاه مختلف كامل باكمله
هذه هي الثلاثين درجه يعني تجعل الكعبه
الى
احد كتفيك هذا
يكون الصلاه تعاد
كانت هذه الحال يعيد الصلاه
وهذه مساله
يثيرها بعض الناس الجاهلين
والذين قصر نظرهم في البحث يثيرون هذه
المساجد في المساجد يثيرون هذه المسائل في
المساجد
ويصبح اهل المسجد الواحد شيعا هذا ياتي
ويقول البوصله تقول هكذا واحنا المفروض
نتجه الى المشرق تماما لا المفروض نتجه
الى
المشرق بين المشرق والجنوب وبعضهم بين
المشرق والشمال وياتي الى المسجد بالبوصله
المعيره وش يقول شوف قبله المسجد هذا
انحرف اربع درجات او خمس درجات
الى اليمين او الشمال
فايش الحل عندهم الحل عندهم اخلع السجاد
كله وغير البناء كله
وعكد الصلاه على الناس يعني احنا الحين
هذا المسجد الحمد لله متسع لو احنا قلنا
لا لازم احنا نتجه الى الزاويه هنا شو
بصير بالصفوف
مصير الصف الاول في خمسه يعني
هذا هو
والابواب كلها بدها تتغير والسجاد بده
يتغير والدنيا على ايش على ماذا
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لم يكن بهذه
الشده
في مساله
التوجه الى القبله لا المقصود
شطر المسجد الحرام اي نحو المسجد الحرام
اذا اصبت الجهه
العامه فقد اصبت قبله الصلاه
نزيد على ذلك يعني انا وجدت في بعض
المساجد في مسجد في
نيويورك كان هذا المسجد مشهور باهله
دائما متقاتلين مع بعض على اتجاه القبله
وصاروا فريقين وصل الموضوع انه واحد يجي
يخطب في زاويه في يوم الجمعه وفي الزاويه
الاخرى خطيب اخر
هذول يقول صلاتهم هذول باطل وهذول يقولوا
صلاه ومذل باطله والشرطه رايحه جايه عليهم
على ايش هذا جهل
جهل
شديد وانا الى يومي هذا ما كنت في مسجد
الا ويجي واحد من هذول الجماعه بدي احكي
مع الامام تفضل يا اخوي شو بدك ويطلع لك
الاوراق والعيارات
الصلاه صلاه مسجدكم طيب شو الحل اللي انت
عندك الحل انا بعرفش الحل مش عندي انا بس
ببين لك المشكله
هذه المساله فيها ساعه
فيها ساعه ولله الحمد
والصحابه رضي الله عنهم والائمه من بعدهم
وعلى راسهم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم فهم
قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
شطر المسجد الحرام يعني ايش يعني نحو
المسجد الحرام الجهه العامه يعني حتى
الكعبه مثلا لو نظرنا الى الكعبه نفسها
انا كنت تكون تصلي عند الكعبه
اليس ثم ناس يصلون
في المسجد الحرام
وهم يصلون الى غير
عطر نصف الكعبه
بعضهم بصلي في الحرم والا فلابد انه نخلي
نخلي الصفوف ما تكون اوسع من من الكعبه
ولا لا اذا الكعبه اذا كانت عشره متر الصف
ما يزيد على عشره متر
لانه في المتر الحادي عشر هذول بصلوا الى
جانب الكعبه مش الى الكعبه صح ولا لا كلام
ما لم يقل به احد من الائمه ابدا
الله عز وجل حول قبله المسلمين
ووطنا
الامر
واهب نفوس المسلمين بقوله سيقول السفهاء
من الناس ما ولاهم عن قبلتهم التي كانوا
عليها هذا كان قبل الامر باتجاه
المسجد الحرام بعد الهجره
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله تعالى
وكان يصلي الى بيت المقدس وقال لجبريل
وددت ان الله صرف وجهي عن قبله اليهود
وقال انما انا عبد فادعو ربك واساله فجعل
يقلب وجهه في السماء يرجو ذلك فانزل الله
عليه قد نرى تقلب وجهك في السماء الايه
وذلك بعد سته عشر شهرا من مقدمه المدينه
قبل بدر بشهرين وكان في ذلك حكم عظيمه
ومحن للمسلمين والمشركين واليهود
والمنافقين فاما المسلمون فقالوا امنا به
كل من عند ربنا وهم الذين هدى الله
ولن تكن كبيره عليهم واما المشركون فقالوا
كما رجع الى قبلتنا يوشك ان يرجع الى
ديننا وما رجع اليها الا انها الحق واما
اليهود فقالوا خالف قبله الانبياء
قبله واما المنافقون فقالوا ما يدري اين
يتوجه ان كانت الاولى حقا فقد تركها وان
كانت الثانيه هي الحق فقد كان على ضلاله
او كان على باطل
وكثرت اقاويل السفهاء من الناس وكانت كما
قال الله تعالى وانها لكبيره الا على
الذين هدى الله
وكانت محنه من الله ليرى من يتبعوا الرسول
ممن ينقلب على عقبيه ولما كان شان القبله
عظيما وطا سبحانه قبلها امر النسخ وقدرته
عليه
يعني في الصوره المقصود في سوره البقره
قال الله تعالى قبل الايات التي تامر
بالتوجه الى القب الى الكعبه اقول
ما ننسخ من ايه او ننسها ناتي بخير منها
او مثلها قال وانه ياتي بخير من المنسوخ
او مثله ثم عقبه بالتوبيخ لمن تعنت على
رسوله ولم ينقذ له
ثم ذكر اختلاف اليهود والنصارى وشهاده
بعضهم على بعض بانهم ليسوا على شيء وقالت
اليهود ليست النصارى على شيء
وقالت النصارى ليست اليهود على شيء وهم
يتلون الكتاب
وحذر عباده من موافقتهم واتباع اهوائهم
ثم ذكر كفرهم به وقولهم ان له
ولدا سبحانه وتعالى ثم اخبر ان له المشرق
والمغرب فاينما ولا عباده وجوههم فثم وجهه
وهو الواسع العليم قال تعالى ولله المشرق
والمغرب فاينما تولوا فثم وجه الله ان
الله واسع عليم
فلعظمته وسعته واحاطته اينما توجه العبد
فثم وجه الله ثم اخبر انه لا يسال رسوله
عن اصحاب الجحيم الذين لا يتابعونه
قال تعالى ولا تسالوا عن اصحاب الجحيم
فاقول الله تعالى ولله المشرق والمغرب
فاينما تولوا فتم وجه الله
وجه الله
هذه الايه
هل هذه الايه
معناها فثم وجه الله يعني كلمه وجه الله
في هذا
السياق هل يعني
به سبحانه وتعالى صفه
الوجه لله
ولا المقصود
وجه الله يعني الشرعي يعني جهه الصلاه
ونسبت هذه الجهه الى الله والى الصلاه
لان المقصود مثل
التشريف لا عندي انا والله عندي تحت عندي
شكرا
ولا معناه اضافه تشريف مثل قول الله تعالى
ناقه الله وبيت الله
صحيح الثاني راجح من اقوال العلماء ان هذه
الايه ليست من ايات الصفات يعني قول الله
تعالى
فثم وجه الله يعني اتجاه الله عز وجل
للصلاه الذي امر به
ومعنى وجه الله بمعنى بيت الله
وناقه الله وكتاب الله وما شابه ذلك
لكن هذا ليس في كل ما يضاف الاصل ان وجه
الله او وجهه في القران بمعنى صفه الله عز
وجل الله يوصف بالوجه
حقيقه له وجه سبحانه وتعالى كما يليق
بجلاله وعظمته
فقوله تعالى
مثلا كل شيء هالك الا وجهه الا وجهه او
قوله تعالى كل من عليها فان ويبقى وجه ربك
هذه من ايات الصفات هذه ايات صفات وجه
الله العلماء يستدلون بهذه الايات على
اثبات الوجه لله سبحانه وتعالى
لكن قوله تعالى في هذه الايه في سوره
البقره فاينما تولوا فثم وجه الله
يعني
فثم جهه الصلاه
فثم جهه الصلاه وهذه الايه ليست من ايات
الصفات فالراجح
يقول ثم اخبره ان اهل الكتاب لن يرضوا لن
يرضوا عنه حتى يتبع ملتهم ولن ترضى عنك
اليهود ولا النصارى حتى تتبع ملتهم ثم ذكر
اهل الكتاب نعمته عليهم وخوفهم باسه ثم
ذكر خليله
داني بيته
واثنى عليه يعني ابراهيم عليه السلام
وبالتالي اسماعيل واخبر انه جعله اماما
للناس
ثم ذكر بيته الحرام وبناء خليله له وهذا
معنى ابراهيم ابراهيم
في السريانيه معناها الاب الرحيم او اب
الجميع
واثنى عليه وهو يقال له الاب الرحيم
هذه التسميه ليست عربيه باجماع العلماء يا
سريانيه معربه
وابراهيم بمعنى
بمعنى اب رحيم
لاتباعه والابوه هنا الابوه الروحيه
قال واثنى عليه واخبر انه جعله اماما
للناس ثم ذكر بيته الحرام وبناءه خليله له
وفي ضمن هذا النبانيه كما هو امام للناس
فكذلك البيت الذي بناه امام له
ثم اخبر انه لا يرغب عن مله هذا الامام
الا اسفه الناس السفه في لغه العرب
وكذلك في القران السفه
بمعنى
من لم يحسن التصرف الذي لا يحسن التصرف
يوصف بالسفه
فمثلا يقول الله تعالى
ولا تؤتوا السفهاء اموالكم
ايش يعني السفهاء اي واحد لا يحسن التصرف
في المال
وان كان من احسن الناس وان كان من اولى
الناس فانه لا يعطى المال السفيه
لماذا لانه يضيع هذا المال لا يحسن التصرف
فقال ولا تؤتوا السفهاء اموالكم التي جعل
الله لكم قيامه وكذلك
قول الله تعالى سيقول السفهاء من الناس من
هم السفهاء من الناس الذين لا يحسنون
الفهم والذين لا يحسنون الفاهم عن الله
سبحانه وتعالى
وكذلك قوله تعالى
ولن يرغب وما يرغب ولا يرغب عمله ابراهيم
الا من سفه نفسه يعني سفه نفسه يعني
يعني اساء التصرف بنفسه التي بين جنبيه
اسال الله تعالى العافيه
يقول ثم اخبروا انه لا يرغب عن مله هذا
الامام الا اسفه الناس ثم امر عباده ان
ياتموا به
ويؤمنوا بما انزل اليه والى النبيين ثم رد
على من قال ان ابراهيم
واهله كانوا هودا او نصارى
وقالوا كونوا هدى او نصارى قلبا المله
ابراهيم حنيفه وما كان من المشركين وجعل
هذا كله توطئه بين يدي تحويل القبله واكد
سبحانه الامر مره بعد مره
وامر به حيث كان رسوله من حيث خرج يعني
ومن حيث خرجت فولي وجهك شطر المسجد الحرم
فيفهم هذا منه
وحيث ما كنتم فولوا وجوهكم شطره يعني في
السفر والحضر
قال واخبر سبحانه ان الذي يهدي
او انه الذي يهدي من يشاء الى صراط
مستقيما الذي هداهم لهذه القبله
وانها لهم وانهم اهلها
لانها افضل القبل وهم افضل الامم
وقال تعالى وكذلك جعلناكم امه وسطا لتكون
شهداء على الناس ويكون الرسول عليكم شهيدا
وما جعلنا القبله التي كنت عليها الا
لنعلم من يتبع الرسول ممن ينقلب على عقبيه
وانها لكبيره الا على من هدى الله
وما كان الله ليضيع ايمانكم ان الله
بالناس لرؤوف رحيم قد نرى تقلب وجهك في
السماء فلنولينك قبله ترضاها واللي وجهك
شطر المسجد الحرام وحيث ما كنتم فولوا
وجوهكم شطر وان الذين اوتوا الكتاب
ويعلمون انه الحق من ربهم ومن الله بغافل
عما يعملون ولا ان اتيت الذين اوتوا
الكتاب بكل ايه ما تبعوا قبلتك وما انت
بتابع قبلتهم وما بعضهم بتابع قبله بعض
يقول ابن القيم رحمه الله
كما اختار لهم افضل الرسل
وافضل الكتب واخراجهم من خير القرون وخصهم
بافضل الشرائع
ومنحهم خير الاخلاق
واسكنهم خير الارض وجعل منازلهم في الجنه
خير المنازل
وموقفهم في القيامه خير المواقف فهم على
تل
عالناس تحته
فسبحان من يختص برحمته من يشاء وذلك فضل
الله يؤتيه من يشاء والله ذو الفضل العظيم
واخبر سبحانه انه فعل ذلك لئلا يكون للناس
عليهم حجه يعني ما عندهم اي شيء يستطيعون
ان يردوا او يحتج به على المسلمين
ولكن الظالمين يحتجون عليهم بتلك الحجج
التي ذكرت
ولا تعارض او ولا تعارض الرسل الا بها
وامثالها ولا تعارض الرسل الا بها
وامثالها يعني الحجج الداحظه التي
يقولونها فيما بينهم وهم انفسهم ليسوا
بمقتنعين بهذه الحجج وكل من قدم
على اقوال الرسل سواها فحجته من جنس حجج
هؤلاء
لاحظوا الان ماذا يقول ابن القيم رحمه
الله ويذكر حجج الكفار على المسلمين
حجج اعداء الرسل على الرسل
يا حجج داحظه
وحجج مردود عليها وحجج متناقضه
لكن هذه الحجج
وجميع ما يحتج به على الرسل
سوى هذه الحجود الحجج المذكوره
فحجته من جنس حجج هؤلاء
واخبر سبحانه انه فعل ذلك ليتم نعمته
عليهم وليهديهم
ثم ذكر نعمتهم عليهم بارسال رسوله
وانزال كتابه
يزكيهم به
ويعلمهم الكتاب والحكمه ويعلمهم ما لم
يكونوا يعلمون
ثم امرهم بذكره وشكره اذ بهما
يستوجبون تمام النعمه والمزيد
ويستجلبون ذكره ومحبته لهم ثم امرهم بما
لا يتم ذلك لهم الا بالاستعانه به وهو
الصبر والصلاه
واخبر انه مع الصابرين واتم نعمته وعليهم
مع القبله بان شرع لهم الاذان في اليوم
والليله خمس مرات
وزادهم في الظهر والعصر والعشاء ركعتين
اخريين بعد ان كانت ثنائيه وكل هذا بعد
مقدمه المدينه بعدما كانت ثنائيه يعني
الصلوات في الاصل كانت ركعتين ركعتين هكذا
قالت عائشه رضي الله عنها عن صحيح الامام
مسلم تقول عائشه بما مفاده
تقول
فرضت فرضت الصلاه وركعتين
فزيد عليها في الحظر يعني
النسخ
وبقيت في السفر
استدل بهذا الحديث او بهذا الاثر كثير من
العلماء
على ان القصر في السفر واجب
القصر قصر الصلاه في السفر واجب ايش يعني
واجب
بعض الناس لا يفرق بين القصر والجمع الجمع
هذا شيء مستحب او جائز
هذا شيء جائز
صحيح ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان يجمع الصلاه للحاجه
هو مسافر
يعني اذا كان في الطريق ماشي
وقف للصلاه
فانه يجمع الصلوات يجمع الظهر الى العصر
يجمع المغرب الى العشاء اما جمع تقديم
وجمع تاخير
لكن اذا كان ما في حاجه لجمع الصلاه
فانه كان
يقصر الصلاه ولا يجمع
ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني مثلا الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
قصر الصلاه 18 يوم في تبوك مثلا
فلما خرج الى
غزوه تبوك
فانه قصر الصلاه جمع الصلاه 18 يوم هناك
في تبوك وهو يستنى الجيش ولم ياتي
ففي الطريق
غالب الطريق الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
جمع الصلوات
انه ماشي في الطريق
جمع الظهر الى العصر والمغرب الى العشاء
ماشي
[Silence]
فانه يستمر في القصر ولكن لا يجمع يجمع
للحاجه هل يجوز له الجمع يجوز لكن ليست
سنه سنه انه يصلي كل صلاه في وقتها لكن
ايش
مقصوره يقصر الصلاه
اذا وصل الانسان
الى حيث اقامته
فانه ماذا
فانه يتم هذه مساله مشهوره الخلاف فيها
بين العلماء وكثر كثره كلامهم في هذه
المساله
ويقول شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله في فتاويه في
مجموع
فتاويه جمع ابن قاسم يقول رحمه الله
ما معناه
من
اراد ان يخرج من الخلاف وان يحتاط
فانه يقصر ثلاثه ايام
واما من اراد اتباع المحفوظ من السنه وسنه
الصحابه والسلف
فانه يقصر ما دام خارج بلده الذي يقيم فيه
ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني
الانسان مثلا يذهب للعمره يذهب للحج
يصل مكه ويبقى فيها عشره ايام 15 يوم او
يصل الى المدينه يقعد فيها في الاوتيل
فهل يتم ويصلي صلاه المقيم الجواب لا يقصر
الصلاه صحيح اذا صلى وراء امام متم لا
الحين بيتم الصلاه لانه بتبع الامام
لكن ما دام في
مدام في غير بلده الذي يقيم فيه فانه يقصر
الصلاه
هذا كله مبني على ماذا مبني على تقسيم
الناس
بعض الفقهاء قسموا الناس الى ثلاثه اقسام
قالوا عندك اول شيء
المقيم هذا شانه واضح
ثاني اشي عندك مسافر
وزادوا ثالث
وفي الثالث في القسم الثالث هذا الذي فيه
الخلاف
فزاد بعض الفقهاء
فقالوا وثم
مسافر مقيم
المسافر واضح والمقيم واضح لكن مين هو
المسافر المقيم
قالوا المسافر المقيم الذي يصل الى المكان
الذي يريد ان يقضي في حاجته
وما يكون على هيئه المسافر خلاص يكون في
الاوتيل او يكون في بيت او يكون في كذا ما
هو في القباب ما هو في الطريق الان هو
مسافر مقيم
ماشي هو مسافر مقيم ايش احكام
المسافر المقيم ما له احكام لانه احنا لما
نبحث في القران والسنه
نجد الناس الى قسمين صح ولا لا يوم
ضعنكم ويوم اقامتكم الله قسم الناس الى
قسم
المسافر والمقيم
والسنه كلها ماشيه على ايش المسافر
والمقيم
لكن القسم الثالث هذا
الذي هو المسافر المقيم هذا بدنا نجيب له
احكام منين
لا له احكام المقيم ولا له احكام المسافر
كيف هذه
فهذا التقسيم في ضعف
والاستدلال عليه صعب صعب
لذلك اختلف العلماء الذين يقولون بهذا
القول
اختلفوا على كيفيه
احكام هذا القسم الثالث مسافر المقيم هل
يجمع ويقصر ثلاثه ايام ولا اربعه ولا خمسه
ولا عشره ولا 15 ولا 18 هذه
اكثر المذاهب تقول ماذا ثلاث ايام وهذا
اللي في دهان الناس يعني تسال الناس يقول
لك لا ثلاثه ايام
ماشي سارحين شو بدنا نسوي في الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم
يفتح مكه كعد 15 يوم وهو يقصر شو نسوي
فيها هذه ومن مكه اصلا
طيب ولما راح على تبوك
وقصر الصلاه 18 يوم كما قال ابن عباس شو
نسوي فيها هذه
وهلم جره تصير صعب جدا انه
نفهم النصوص على هذه الطريق وفي المساله
اصعب لسه
يعني في الصحيح ابن عمر رضي الله عنهما
لما كان في الشام
اقام في الشام
من اجل الثلج
سته اشهر وهو يقصر الصلاه الشام يعني في
سوريا دمشق اصل عقر الشام دمشق
وكان في اشياء
وكان في ايش ثلوج
ابن عمر كان مع الجيش هناك وكان مع اصحابي
هناك بده يرجع للمدينه
فمكث
بالشام سته اشهر
وهو يقصر الصلاه صلاه المسافر
بهذا مسافر مقيم ولا لا طب شو نسوي فيه
هذا
بعض الفقهاء علل قال شوف
هو كان
غير مقر بانه سيبقى سته اشهر يعني مش
متاكد
عبروا بقولهم اليوم بكره
يعني ان شاء الله بس الطقس يتحسن نطلع
معقول ابن عمر قاعد في الشام
ينظر الى جبال الثلج ويقول بجوز بكره اصحى
ويكون ان هذول رايحات
يعني اليوم بكره هذه بدها ثلاث اربع اشهر
اقل شيء
وين الثلج هذا بده يروح اليوم وبكره
يعني ابن عمر نظر الى الشتويه هناك وقال
يلا ان شاء الله عسى الاسبوع القادم نسافر
عيار الثلج ينزل ما يذهب الا للصيف
هذا قول ضعيف بن عمر رضي الله عنه واقام
هناك سته اشهر
وقصر الصلاه ليش لانه مكانه واقامته وين
اقامته في المدينه وفي الشام
وانحابس بغير ارادته وحتى لو كان بارادته
فانه غير مكانه لكن لو كان الواحد عنده
بيت هان وبيت هان لا هذيك الساعه هو مقيم
يعني مثلا واحد عنده بيت في البلاد يقعد
فيه سته اشهر وبيت في امريكا يقعد فيه سته
اشهر ماذا يصنع
لا يتم لما بيوصل بيته لانه هذا بيته
ومقيم هناك عنده مصالح هناك وعنده اموال
هناك وعنده
لكن الذي يبقى على هيئه غير المقيم وين
عنوانك عنواني في بلد اخرى وين
اهلك وولدك وشغلك وكل شيء في بلاد اخرى
هذا مسافر هذا غير مقيم
واما قسم المسافر المقيم ما بنعرف شو نسوي
فيه ولذلك اختلف اهل هذا القول اختلافا
كثيرا جدا
فرجح شيخ الاسلام رحمه الله
وابن القيم
وكثير من المحققين سلفا وخلفا على ان
الانسان اما ان يكون مسافرا او مقيما
اذا كان مسافرا فعليه ان يقصر صلاته
واذا كان مقيما فعليه ان يتم بس هذا هو
واما قصر الصلاه
فهذا يكون واما جمع الصلاه فهذا يكون ماذا
للحاجه واحد عنده حاجه بجمع الصلوات حتى
لو كان مقيما وهذا له احكام
سياتي شيء من تفصيلها فيما بعد ان شاء
الله تعالى يقول
ابن القيم ثم امرهم بذكري وشكره اذ بهما
يستوجبون تماما نعمه والمزيد
ويستجلبون ذكرا ومحبته لهم ثم امرهم بما
لا يتم ذلك لهم الا بالاستعانه به وهو
الصبر والصلاه واخبر انه مع الصابرين واتم
نعمته عليهم مع القبله بان شرع لهم الاذان
في اليوم والليله خمس مرات
وزادهم في الظهر والعصر والعشاء ركعتين
اخريين فالاصل للصلانها ركعتين ركعتين
ومن ذلك يقول من قال من العلماء
يعني عشان انا اقول مثلا مستحب انك تقصر
الصلاه
مستحب ايش يعني مستحب يعني اصل شريعه
المسافر انه يتم لكن اذا بده بقصر في فرق
بين هذا وبين ايش
اصلا اللي كان موجب على
المسافر انه يقصر ما له شيء ثالث في
الصحيح ان
قصر الصلاه للمسافر
الصحيح انه يقصر
وزادهم في الظهر والعصر والعشاء ركعتين
اخريين بعد ان كانت ثنائيه وكل هذا بعد
مقدمه المدينه
نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه